[Musique]
et des histoires qu'on voudrait vivre
celles qu'on aimerait oublier et surtout
celles qu'on se raconte en terrasse
c'était pas elle avec qui tu es rentré
c'était l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon Dieu vous voyez ce moment où les
gens vous demandent ce que vous faites
dans la vie et que vous voulez quitter
la conversation
bah c'est ma vie m'a proposé un CDI aux
États-Unis là
c'est ma vie ça aussi c'est ma vie non
ça un peu moins non ça c'est plutôt la
vie de ma podcam tu peux être aussi calé
en couple sans l'être j'ai vu un prof de
PS faire du sport
[Musique]
j'ai pas choisi mes fringues mais non
j'ai pas choisi mes parents
les meufs ne choisissent pas non plus de
ouf
non rien
quand j'avais 5 ans parce qu'ils étaient
dans ma classe à côté de moi arrête avec
le destin arrête avec ça tu veux quoi
toi David
[Musique]
alors la plupart du temps je sais pas où
je dois être du coup je me suis mis là
parce qu'il y a de la place en terrasse